who is  I wish I wish I wish you wish to have  the curse reversed go to the ward and  bring me back a cow as white as milk  he's being scary magic the Cape as red  as blood oh dear how uneasy I feel the  hair is yellow as corn the slipper as  pure as gold go to the  the way to the woods  [Music]  good day mr. wolf and what might be in  your basket  I must find that  [Music]  all will come to a happy end not always  princes and castles why would you run  away it's not quite what I expected  maybe I shouldn't have strayed from the  path  [Music]  you know what's out there in  to shield you from  it's because of you there's a charming  admits  stopwhat I wish it's what you wish we  have one chance don't you see that if  we're gonna get through this we're gonna  do it together did you love me why did  you stray  I was raised to be charming not sincere  stay your child while you can be a child  [Music]  you